[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique du
week end à fin du bras de fer entre
sénateurs et députés ils ont trouvé
finalement un compromis sur la
responsabilité pénale des décideurs dans
le projet de loi prolongeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
il faudra maintenant tenir compte je
signe des compétences des pouvoirs et
des moyens dont dispose l auteur des
faits dans la situation de crise ayant
justifié l'état d'urgence sanitaire
voilà donc pour la nouvelle version
mardi le sénat avait voté un amendement
qui supprimait la possibilité d'engager
la responsabilité pénale des maires pour
une faute caractérisée et dans la foulée
les députés avaient rajouté un autre
élément de contexte et à l'état des
connaissances scientifiques au moment
des faits et certains y ont vu une loi
d'aministie pour l'exécutif d'où la
question de notre débat ce soir
responsable mais pas coupable nous
sommes avec patrick mennucci ancien
député du parti socialiste et conseiller
municipal à marseille bonsoir patrick
mennucci ainsi que georges kuzmanovic
fondateur de république souveraine
bonsoir georges kuzmanovic merci à tous
les deux ans soit entre sur rt france on
va d'abord écouté la députée la
république en marche
aurore bergé l'un de ces tweets a
beaucoup fait réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux cette semaine nous proposerons
une adaptation de la législation pour
effectivement protéger les mères
pénalement mais aussi toutes les
personnes dépositaires d'une mission de
service public dans le cadre des
opérations de déconfinement des
propositions que je porterai avec la
république en marche
georges kuzmanovic à l'heure après ce
tweet certains ont dit c'est une loi qui
va être remanié pour protéger l'exécutif
en cas de poursuites
la loi a été remanié il ya un compromis
finalement entre les sénateurs et les
députés qu'en pensez vous j'en pense
qu'on voit bien que les publics en
marche et en particulier l'exécutif
l'ensemble du gouvernement un peu peur
un peu peur de la réaction populaire et
il faut quand même rappeler que ce n'est
pas tant le personnel politique qui
porte plainte contre ce gouvernement
mais bien les médecins bien des
soignants ou des citoyens est
directement au pénal comme vous le savez
en dehors du président de la république
tous les autres y compris le premier
ministre sont responsables pénalement de
leurs décisions
alors si évidemment on peut critiquer la
gestion catastrophique que tout le monde
considère comme catastrophique et les
mensonges je pense en particulier aux
masques ou test est visiblement deux
tiers des français considère que le
gouvernement leur a menti à plusieurs
reprises lors de cette crise ce qui est
je crois condamné et pour lequel ils
sont réellement coupable profondément au
sens profond du terme c'est que c'est
leur modèle de société qui s'effondre là
et qui est qui montre son hymne à 4
incapacité à organiser la vie ensemble
ce sont des gens qui tout au long des
années passées dans d'autres
gouvernements et de manière accélérée
dans celui ci on détruit les pouvoirs
publics la sécurité sociale l'hôpital il
faut rappeler qu'il y avait avant cette
avant cette crise douze mois de grève
des personnels de santé sur toute la
france
douze mois et pendant 12 mois ce
gouvernement s'est moqué d'eux quand ils
disaient il faut plus de moyens
donc on voit bien qu'il ya effectivement
une grave responsabilité et je considère
qu'on ne gouverne pas impunément
et donc voilà ce sont des gens qui ont
voulu ce système de libre échange total
où on ne produit plus de médicaments
france on ne produit plus de
respirateurs on est incapable de réagir
rapidement à une crise quelles qu'elles
soient
eh bien ces gens là ont failli et leur
modèle a totalement failli qu'en
pensez-vous patrick mennucci ps qu'on
dirige impunément comme le dit georges
kiejman aux bus quand on voit la
nouvelle
actions je cite il faudra tenir compte
des compétences des pouvoirs et des
moyens dont dispose est l'auteur des
faits qu est ce que cela veut dire
est-ce que ça met à l'abri l'exécutif
d'abord permettez moi de penser que le
texte qui a été voté par la commission
mixte paritaire
cet après midi n'apporte pas grand chose
parce qu'en réalité le juge a toujours
les moines les moyens il a mal devoir
d'examiner
quelle est la situation quels étaient
les connaissances de celui qui est mis
en cause qu'elle est est ce qu'il avait
fait les diligences suffisante ou est-ce
que à titre personnel il avait il
pouvait être mis en cause pour une
violation manifeste délibérée
d'obligation de sécurité si c'était le
cas ce texte ne règle rien si demain une
élue locale le maire puisque c'était
surtout pour eux que cela a été fait est
mis en cause et qu'il est démontré par
le juge qu'il a fait une faute
caractérisée qui expose autrui à un
dommage auquel cet autrui ne pouvait
avoir comme connaissance et bien il sera
condamné et le texte de la commission
mixte paritaire n'y changera rien il
s'agite il s'agit d'un texte purement
politique d'un accord purement
politiques de l'assemblée et du sénat
je peux le comprendre parfaitement parce
que le gouvernement a besoin de rassurer
les magistrats qui le dit ou mardi ou
mercredi vont commencer à ouvrir leur
école mais je veux
redire juridiquement ce texte apporte
d'ailleurs nous allons pouvoir le
vérifier puisque pour la première fois
un texte connaissent tiko concernant
l'urgence sanitaire les problèmes de
coheed va être transféré devant le
conseil constitutionnel puisque cet
après midi patrick kanner le président
du groupe socialiste au sénat a indiqué
que le texte allait être transféré
devant les sages donc qui du roi
également là quelque chose d'intéressant
c'est que le conseil constitutionnel va
regarder la constitutionnalité de ce que
nous venons de nous venons de parler
mais aussi d'autres éléments de ce texte
vous l'avez dit cette loie s'être
maniement de la loi en tout cas avait
été fait pour protéger les mères 1
écoutez philippe val le président ait
l'air de la commission des faits au
sénat mardi
voilà son attention quand un maire un
chef d'atelier un directeur d'école
respecte les obligations particulières
de prudence qui sont prévues par les
lois et les règlements qui ont été mises
en place pour lutter contre le coc vide
je ne vois pas pourquoi on lui ferait
courir un risque pénal
en revanche ce qui pose les règles il ne
s'agit pas de les mettre à l'abri
georges kuzmanovic la règle de ce projet
de loi elle est valable pour tout le
monde
ou est ce que les mères sont bien à
l'abri selon vous non mais il y a il ya
déjà un cadre légal comme l'a très bien
dit mais sur l'inutile juste un instant
qui date des années 90 et auquel a
participé un certain régis de castelnau
qui est qui parfaitement expliquer cela
dans sur son blog le droit et dans un
interview au figaro que les maires sont
déjà protégés en fait pénalement
quand ils ne sont pas informés les
risques et qui n'ont pas les moyens de
mettre en oeuvre les politiques qui leur
sont demandés de même que l'on demande
de mettre en oeuvre donc si vous avez
par exemple une directive qui vient d'en
haut qui vous dit ouvrez les écoles le
11 mai il faut qu'il y ait absolument
quatre toilettes mais qu'il n'y a qu'une
dans les écoles
le pot mère n'est pas responsable de
l'inadéquation de du bâtiment à cette
crise particulière non ce qui se passe
là c'est que on a au lieu d'avoir un
exécutif qui reviennent sur sur sa ligne
politique habituelle au lieu de
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on peut
organiser la résilience
comment ça se fait que en allemagne il
existe un tissu industriel
protégé par ses loi qui interdit de
vendre les entreprises stratégiques
comment se fait-il que juste le côté de
la frontière il y a une capacité pour
l'exécutif de réagir rapidement en cas
de crise et d'éviter tant de morts et
bien ce gouvernement plutôt que de
tenter de trouver le des carabistouilles
et des moyens pour se protéger
éventuellement ou débattre politiquement
de manière parfaitement inutile encore
une fois ça ne concerne pas les maires
et bien il aurait mieux fait de
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on
organise la résidence à la prochaine
crise qui peut être une prochaine vague
or il ne le fait pas et le déconfinement
qui arrive le 11 mai s'annonce sous de
très mauvais auspices
encore une fois en termes d'accès aux
masques aux tests au moyen de contrôler
et à l'organisation global de ceux des
confinement qui n'est pas du tout encore
une fois je prends l'exemple de
l'allemagne où les choses ont l'air un
peu mieux penser que qu'ici donc tous
les deux vous êtes d'accord pour dire
qu'il ya déjà une loi c'est la fameuse
loi fauchon du 10 juillet 2000 néanmoins
patrick mennucci soixante et une plainte
minimum contre des ministres et des
décideurs physique ont déjà été déposées
auprès de la cour de justice de la
république
est-ce que ça a des chances d'être
instruit selon vous c'est tout à fait
autre chose
ce dont on parle et ce n'est pas du tout
dans le même cadre le débat de
l'assemblée nationale de ces derniers
jours n'a évidemment rien à voir avec la
commission avec la cjr qui
et saisi conformément à l'article 78 1
de la constitution de 1958 et qui va
avoir d'abord ça avant que soit la
civière
sa commission des requêtes qui va devoir
dire si les 63 plaintes mais il y en
aura certainement encore d'autres sont
possiblement jugeable devant une
institution pénale particulière qui est
celle qui jugeait les ministres je
rappelle que le président république
mais georges elle a dit je crois en
début de leur première intervention et
lui et n'a ne peut pas être poursuivi
dans quelconque circonstance pendant son
mandat pour des faits de direction du
pays sauf si on avoir trahison des
choses qui n'ont rien à voir évidemment
donc en fait que peut-il se passer peut
se passer
qu' il y ait une recherche d'homicide
involontaire
c'est une des questions qui sera posée
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
abstention de prendre part des membres
du gouvernement des mesures pour éviter
la combattre liste c'est ça les
questions qui peuvent être proposées à
la civière
moi je ne connais pas les réponses mais
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai
le sentiment et c'est pas l'intervention
de georges et que vos invités qui me
détournera de ça c'est qu'il ya une
volonté de pédales ce pays c'est à dire
à partir du moment où un sens bien il ya
une difficulté politique de changer les
choses
les citoyens ne se tournent plus vers
les partis d'opposition mais se tournent
plus vers d'autres formes de direction
politique du pays mais ils se tournent
vers la justice moi personnellement je
trouve que c'est dommage parce que je ne
veux pas faire autrement patrick
mennucci comme au faudrait il faire
autrement mais je
je pense que c'est parce qu'il ya une
faiblesse de la politique parce que les
français ne croient plus dans les partis
politiques et à la capacité de
changement est ce que je regrette
profondément
est ce que je pouvais juste à certains
points de vue et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
tournent vers la justice
alors nous verrons ce que dira la
commission des requêtes de la civière
mais je crois qu'il ne faut pas pour
ceux qui portent ces plaintes avoir trop
d'illusions et puis il faudra aussi que
nous demandions quand même d'une
certaine façon si on dit edouard
philippe les responsables des morts dans
les ehpad ou madame b loubet et
responsable des contaminations en prison
il faut là aussi peut-être qu'on se
regarde nous mêmes regardez est ce qu'on
n'a pas acheté un voile pudique sur le
sort des personnes très âgées
est ce qu'on n'est pas est-ce qu'on ne
détourne pas le regard quand on parle de
la prison est ce qu'on n'est pas
toujours à demander plus de personnes en
prison plus de cdd donc c'est aussi une
question qui est posée à la société elle
n'est pas posée qu'aux dirigeants mais
c'était ne décide pas en l'occurrence
patrick mennucci vous voulez réagir jean
georges kiejman au dit oui d'abord il
est clair et net qu'il ya anguille sous
roche puisque cela l'information nous
vient directement des membres haut
placés du gouvernement sur ces questions
là madame agnès buzyn ancien ministre de
la santé qui a lors d'une interview
déclaré qu'elles avaient elles été
alertés et qu'elle avait alerté le
gouvernement dès fin janvier de la crise
grave que représentait le coguic 10 19
mais quand la crise du corps d'un virus
pour la france dans ce cas si c'est vrai
et si elle le dit publiquement
a priori il doit y ait des chances que
ce soit vrai vu qu'ils étaient mises de
la santé et pas au zinc d'un des cafés
bars et là il ya un choix graves dont
est responsable le gouvernement par
exemple d'avoir organisé de manière
totalement inconséquente le premier tour
des élections municipales
sachant parfaitement que le second tour
n'aura jamais lieu les créant
na risques complémentaires de
supplémentaire de contamination par
contre je ne suis pas d'accord avec
patrice sur le fait que madère rafik les
il y avait problème
les citoyens ont un peu ras-le-bol des
partis politiques existants et
anciennement de gouvernement dont le
parti socialiste la faute il a rappelé
que ont été supprimés sous françois
hollande est il plus donc les
établissements de préparation à la
résilience salutaire laisse ou madame
touraine et dans son cabinet madame
touré a admis la santé health ou
françois hollande et dans son cabinet il
y avait monsieur attal monsieur véranda
calme de la santé monsieur salomon
l'actuel directeur général de la santé
ces gens là ont décidé qu'il y avait
trente masques en france et que ils sont
conformes à la politique qui a été menée
auparavant et qui est menée après et
toujours par ce gouvernement je reste
ici avec des masques les démarques
paraît même qu'ils pouvaient recommander
des masques le monde a aimé et surtout
ce je pense que les citoyens et ça se
voit bien depuis la crise des gilet
jaune et la révolte du corps médical
on en a ras le bol d'avoir un pays où on
ne peut pas faire et d'avoir des
gouvernants qui ne peuvent pas gouverner
et s'excuse systématiquement de dire
c'est de libre échange c'est l'union
européenne
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas avoir d'
usine ici ça coûte trop chère madame
monsieur et ce gouvernement je tiens à
ajouter ceci ce gouvernement n'a pas
pris la mesure de ce qui se passe parce
qu'il continue
il y a actuellement en cours une
climatisation l'office national des
forêts une pétition qui a été lancée par
donc c'est important le jour il y aura
des incendies graves parce que les des
choses on n'aura pas fait le reste je
suis d'accord très bien mais c'est juste
pour dire que ce gouvernement continue à
saborder toute souveraineté
tant pis tant industrielle que populaire
c'est-à-dire le contrôle populaire sur
ce qu'il se passe et je pense que la
réaction de certains en particulier des
soignants qui a porté plainte devant la
justice est une réaction saine d'un
peuple qui veut reconquérir sa
souveraineté la démocratie et ne pas la
laisser à 10
à lyon il ya aussi des policiers qui ont
porté plainte
une rixe dans un sens plus exact il y a
une responsabilité pénale qui pèse
également sur les dirigeants
d'entreprises d'où cet appel du medef
cette semaine écoutez il est important
que dans cette période exceptionnelle on
prenne des dispositions qui n'exonère
certainement pas les entreprises de leur
obligation de moyens mais qui met à
l'abri les chefs d'entreprise d'une
obligation de résultat
on est face à une pandémie on ne peut
prétendre ni de près ni de loin que
c'est l'entreprise qui est à l'origine
du coc vide
patrick mennucci on avait vu un la
justice a ordonné la fermeture d'une
usine à sandouville une usine automobile
les patrons ne sont pas non plus à
l'abri est ce que c'est justifié selon
vous mais les patrons sont concernés
comme on a parlé des élus locaux mais ça
concerne également les patrons la
décision de la commission mixte
paritaire cet après midi mais qui ne
règle rien en réalité
parce que ça existait déjà mais je vais
me dire mon j'ai pas ou alors gm a pas
bien compris je n'ai pas dit que c'était
les partis politiques qui devaient tout
faire hacher dis simplement que le fait
qu' on voit beaucoup de gens allaient
vers la cjr
c'est aussi parce qu'il n'ya pas le
sentiment que il y a quelque chose qui
peut s'opposer au système politique
habituelle et de l'agglo d'agde ne sont
pas ne sommes pas vraiment un homme d
accord simplement je pense qu'il faut
pas se servir de ces choses là il faut
attendre
il va y avoir des enquêtes sur les
masques par exemple on a cru longtemps
gouvernement de françois hollande avait
liquidé les basco or on s'aperçoit il
est très bon article du monde
je vous recommande et qui montre que au
début du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
françois hollande avait laissé lui mais
ses équipes avec les citizens
gerdemann alors est-ce que l'exécutif
doit rendre des comptes patrick mennucci
clairement oui mais moi je crois que
l'exécutif borneraient compte au bac
d'abord c'est au peuple ne l'attendait
pas qu'il peut y avoir des individus
georget a parlé à anduze et si
effectivement et ce qui est dit et venez
je pense que ça n'évitera pas la cour de
justice de la république
mais après la question c'est est ce que
les français sortent une capacité de
juger leurs dirigeants et de juger les
systèmes politiques pour cela il ya des
élections
et moi je pense que le ce qui montrera
la bonne santé de notre pays et c'est un
non j'utilise à dessein
après cette crise sanitaire espère la
plus brève possible même si nous savons
qu'il faut encore se protéger pendant
les mois qui viennent c'est de retrouver
une vie démocratique qui nous permettra
de continuer à travailler pour le
chargement politique d'un spi j'ai
presque c'est ça qui est important
aujourd'hui est effectivement le
gouvernement le président de la
république
oh mais comme d'aram sur cette période
avec leur cure n'aura sans doute une
image plus vers elle et moi je ne suis
pas aujourd'hui au moment où l'ue tome
comme concept cette pandémie obligatoire
en main comme vaincus que c'est le
moment de déverser tout ce qu'on a
déversé il y aura un mouvement pour que
cela arrive
elle est en même temps comme premier
tout l'édifice qu'ils mènent aux
béthunois est très peu de temps est ce
que c'est le bon moment en tout cas les
ya des usines qui ferment je reviens aux
entrepreneurs qui sont aussi
responsables est-ce que c'est justifié
la démocratie c'est toujours le bon
moment et je reprendrai celui que 1,5
cité logistiaa indûment cité le
président applique messieurs clément
sont alors qu'il y avait une vraie
guerre alors que nous étions en 1917 il
refusait que healy et loi d'interdiction
de s'exprimer et lui même pendant les
trois ans elle trois premières années de
la guerre critiquer vertement le
gouvernement pour ses erreurs dans la
gestion de la crise donc on a deux
les politiques en boule de fer et les
citoyens grande de faire maintenant ce
qui va arriver parce que ce gouvernement
est l'héritier de politique de
destruction de l'industrie en france
11 on a pris la mesure la plus la pire
recommandé par le m s à savoir confiné
tout le pays
en même temps en deux mois ce qui est
une catastrophe pour l'économie tout le
monde comprend bien et le sens bien
demain ce sera un autre crise celle du
chômage on en reparlera mais ça veut
dire que je finis là dessus nous aux
républiques souveraines nous sommes pour
que l'on réindustrialiser le pays on
fasse une souveraineté sanitaires ce qui
veut dire qu'il y ait des usines qui
produisent et médicaments du matériel
sanitaire est qu'elle soit protégée par
des world protectionnistes intelligente
plutôt que de rester dans ce système
complètement stupide qui nous fait
perdre et les nos métiers et nos emplois
et le capacité à résister
merci c'est la fin de ce débat merci
patrick mennucci merci georges kiejman
aux vivres ont participé à ce face à
face politique par écran interposé
confinement oblige
merci à vous de votre fidélité restez
avec nous ces raretés france
[Musique]